easy and mega nice Italian sparking
romance rumors with this PDA filled clip
posted to the rapper's Instagram story
in the clip the rapper can be seen
cuddling up to Meg while repeatedly
kissing her cheek both making in G easy
were in Miami over the weekend for the
Super Bowl
G played mr. Jones night clubs big game
weekend on Sunday and Megan took the
stage at Bacardi's big game party on
Saturday it's worth noting that the
outfit Meg's rockin in this now deleted
video is the same ensemble she sports in
this clip she posted showing her and G
throwing back shots with friends I mean
and this isn't the only evidence
pointing towards a potential romance
check out this bootylicious photo G
Instagram dove Meg on Monday along with
four blue heart emojis that's GE Z's
most recent ex Yasmine Wynalda mess IG
stories post in which she's seemingly
reacting to his steamy makeout sesh with
hot girl Meg the 21 year old Victoria's
Secret model Instagram the clip of Nicki
Minaj laughing hysterically and labeled
it moot oh yeah she also and followed
gez Yasmin and G were first linked last
February and dated through at least
September the same month they were seen
together at the savage xfinty show
after-party where they had a near runnin
with G's previous ex girlfriend Halsey I
think the world of her she's a really
special person a really special human
being that besides you know how great of
an artist she is but
human I love it Gian Halsey is foot in
2018 after about a year of dating and
we're guessing she won't be sending any
congrats to her former BAE the 25 year
old singer had her own encounter with a
heckler who kept screaming GE Z's name
during her performance at Budweiser's
but ex Miami priest Superbowl bash over
the weekend and she let him have it
I know she's authentically herself and
unapologetically herself
[Music]